the Chinese Communist Party cracking
down on protesters as they rally against
covid lockdowns we are now learning
America's largest company Apple has
restricted the use of its airdrop
feature in the Communist Nation it
allowed users to share content between
Apple devices and Dodge China's
censorship and now Elon Musk says
Apple's threatening to boot Twitter from
its App Store so how did we get to a
point where big tech companies consider
280 characters a bigger threat than the
Communist Regime let's bring in South
Carolina Republican senator Lindsey
Graham Senator good to have you here
today why thank you are we here today
and why are we not going tougher on
China for Its Behavior
a money uh you got to be in people in
China corporate appeasement of the
Chinese Communist party is pretty
rampant I like Apple they're a great
American company but the Chinese
Communist Party writes the rules of the
road and to do business in China you
either leave the customer base or you
follow their lead the MBA has appeased
China the movie industry appeases China
now apple and I think this is uh this is
a mistake so you've got uh Apple
threatening to take Twitter out of the
Apple Store and at the same time doing
the bidding of the Communist Party
restricting sharing of information to
people or trying to protest I think we
got it backwards here and I think it
drives this is just money and market
share yeah well obviously too Apple has
got a lot invested in this because the
protests against the coveted lockdowns
at Foxconn
factories looks like apple is going to
be short some 6 million iPhone pros this
year so that's definitely going to hurt
their bottom line but it also also gets
into the idea of free speech when we
pull back to 30 000 feet here and we
take a look at the idea that Apple
according to Elon Musk May re-examine
whether or not the Twitter app is
available on the Apple Store and musk
also tweeted this quote Apple has mostly
stopped advertising on Twitter do they
hate free speech in America
well all I can say that apple is a
private company and Twitter's a private
company they have their differences I
would hope that Apple would keep
allowing Twitter to be part of the of
the Apple store but big Tech you can't
sue these people because of section 230
and there's no regulatory scheme that
works so I'm going to unveil a digital
Regulatory Commission to deal with
social media companies like apple and
Twitter and Google we need some
regulatory environment to control the
abuses of power here so I'm going to do
that with Elizabeth Warren you look for
something that can bring us together in
Washington social media is out of
control they need to be regulated in
some fashion and I think that brings
both parties together okay so then maybe
you agree with with career job here at
the Biden White House who said this
listen
we're all keeping a close eye on this
we're all monitoring uh what's what's
currently occurring and we see you know
we see it with our own eyes of what you
all are reporting and just for for
ourselves what's happening on Twitter so
the White House says it's keeping a
close eye on what is happening at
Twitter do you agree with yeah with that
now I think somebody needs to regulate
social media companies who are the
largest companies on the planet if they
take down your content I like Elon Musk
well that may be somebody in charge of
Twitter tomorrow that I don't like so
what happens if you're a consumer if
Twitter or any other group takes your
content down you have to appeal to the
company or itself I want to create a
process where a consumer can make their
case that my rights were abused to
somebody other than the company I'm not
asking the White House to watch Twitter
we have a commission for Securities we
have a commission for about every
activity in America to make sure the
consumer is protected when it comes to
social media your privacy is at risk
your content can be taken down because
somebody doesn't like you or what you're
saying we need to have a system to deal
with those problems
now Senator we started off by talking
about the covid protests in China and
kobit still is a matter of some
controversy here in the United States
from the standpoint of many people have
lost their jobs or been decommissioned
from the military because they refuse to
get the vaccine you have introduced
legislation to address the military
aspect of that tell us about that
well so in the coming days and weeks
up to 30 000 people will be discharged
to the military for a simple reason they
refuse to take the vaccine
at a time when we were falling short of
recruitment we're discharging
able-bodied people most of them have had
coveted because they refused to take the
vaccine for con for personal reasons I
think that's silly I think that's insane
so what I want to do is stop the policy
of discharging someone who's qualified
to serve simply because they won't take
a coveted shot it's odd to me that
you're willing to get shot for your
country but we're going to kick it kick
it out of the military because you don't
take a shot millions of illegal
immigrants have come across a broken
border unvaccinated
and and we're talking about not
expelling them under title 42 we got a
policy to take able-bodied men and women
out of military service at a time where
falling short of recruitment that needs
to stop uh Senator I want to ask you
about what is about to happen down in
Georgia we've seen you campaigning quite
a bit yeah with Herschel Walker there
seems to be some uh record turnout as
far as the early vote is concerned what
does that tell you about what is going
to happen for your party there in that
state
well the Democrats are much better about
getting early votes spanked I doubt if
these are people that there probably
would have voted anyway they're just
voting early we've got Republicans
trained to vote only on Election Day
that's a mistake I think we should be
voting at every opportunity including
election day but 59 percent of the
people in Georgia disapprove of Joe
Biden as president 59 of the people in
Georgia like uh Governor Kemp so
Herschel Walker will be an ally of
Governor Kemp and will oppose the Biden
agenda if you want to help Herschel
Walker go to Team herschel.com if we get
50 50 that means we share power
Democrats 51.49 if Warnock wins means
they're in charge of all the Committees
this is a very big deal for you and your
family he's being outspent four to one
go to Team herschel.com if you can give
five or ten bucks it will help him close
the gap
Senator what's your your sense of the
enthusiasm among Republicans uh there in
the state of Georgia because you know
not everyone gets the Nuance that if
it's a 50 50 Senate versus a 5149 Senate
that the operations are going to be
quite different
well there's a poll after day where it's
basically tied we had 3.6 million people
vote in the general election you're
probably going to have around two eight
to three two if Republicans will turn
out we will win it's a plus nine do you
prefer a republican in the senate or a
Democrat in the Senate the generic
ballot is plus nine for republicans
Kemp won almost 54 percent of the vote
the road to victory for Herschel is
there Republicans have to turn out if
they do we win if they don't we lose and
if Warner comes back to the Senate is a
very bad deal for conservatism Herschel
Walker is an African-American willing to
put his name behind the conservative
cause we owe it to Herschel who's been
belittled and beaten up beyond belief to
help him team herschel.com it really
matters who comes out of Georgia in this
runoff which is a week from yesterday we
can win this it is there for Republicans
to win if our people turn out and the
money helps get people turned out we
need the money to turn our voters
teamherchel.com it will help which leads
me to my last question Senator and with
Democrats already having majority in the
Senate what what is this what's at stake
with this seat
okay if warneck comes back that's
another vote for the Biden agenda if
Herschel comes up here he's not going to
empower the most radical agenda agenda
modern history if it's a 50 50 Senate
that means all the Committees have equal
representation if it's 51-49 they have
one more vote then we don't every
committee it matters in terms of the
type judges you get in 2024 we have a
very favorable map we don't want to be
down 5149 going into 2024 and Herschel
Walker is a breakthrough candidate like
Tim Scott and John James we need more
people of color on wanting to be
Republicans and more women more
minorities so this is a very big deal
for us it matters how the Senate is run
it matters to the future of the
Republican party and if you can afford
it and I know it's tough out there go to
teamhearsel.com and a lot of people
giving a little will close the gap
herschel's been outspent four to one
all right Senator it's always good to
spend time with you thank you hope you
have a good Christmas thank you thanks
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else